the reviews for Martin Scorsese's the
Irishman are in and they're about as
fantastic as reviews can get based on
Charles brands 2004 book I heard you
paint houses the Irishman stars Robert
DeNiro as former mafioso and alleged
hitman Frank the Irishman Sheeran who
details the dirty deeds he did while
working for the Bufalino crime family
and there's particular focus on his
involvement in a disappearance of
reported murder of international
brotherhood of teamsters leader jimmy
hoffa played by Al Pacino the Irishman
had its world premiere at the 57th New
York Film Festival on September 27th
2019 when critics fell head-over-heels
for it as of September 30th the Irishman
stands a flawless 100 percent approval
rating on Rotten Tomatoes writing for
indieWIRE Eric Cohen said of the
legendary directors latest it takes less
than 5 minutes to establish the Irishman
in Martin Scorsese's a mistakable voice
the mood is at once taut and funny the
essence of Scorsese's ability to
humanize the mob is prickly mature men
just a few notes shy of loveable in that
fundamental disconnect between endearing
people and a psychotic world they
represent the movie presents a
fascinating on-ramp to America's
obsession with organized crime Cohn
added that the Irishman is bursting with
Scorsese's trademark style and proves
that the director is quote more alive
than ever at the movie minute joanna
lang field wrote Scorsese's mob epic
demands and commands confident enough to
play with traditional storytelling as
well as cutting-edge technology this is
thrilling work from artists at their
prime it's a marvel to watch the piece
as a whole with its shifting tones
laugh-out-loud funny breaks and it's
sneaky very human heartbeats Jay Don
Birnam a splash report says that there's
more to the Irishman than meets the eye
right saying as with everything score
says he touches the Irishman is plenty
more than just a criminal's biography
like many of his other films it is a
reflection on human nature and whether
and how greed loyalty betrayal and
regrets drive a life it is also more
fundamentally an aging directors look
back with nostalgia at his own work as
forgotten episodes in American history
and about the meaning not just of life
but a humanity itself / films Chris even
jalisa called the Irishman a funny
melancholy masterpiece in his review
right saying this is not Goodfellas this
is not casino this is Scorsese at its
most reflective
crafting a masterwork that finds a
filmmaker
thing on everything he's done and what
it's all amounted to the results are
breathtaking and one of Martin
Scorsese's very best films thus telecast
of the Irishman received high praise
from critics the vast majority of whom
felt each star turned in career best
performances vulture critic David
Edelstein was impressed by the major
players in the Irishman but was
completely floored by Joe Pesci as
Russell Bufalino Edelstein wrote in his
review
I heard all sorts of hazhar about Pacino
and he is wonderful but it's Pesci who
thrilled me to the core
Matt Zoller Seitz of Roger Ebert calm
wrote of the Irishman solidifies De Niro
as quotes one of the greats team
stealing straight men in film history
while Vogue's Taylor Antrim said that
Pacino is just a scenery-chewing rias's
Hoffer AV club's a a doubt commended
both to Quad Cities direction and De
Niro's and during acting chops in
writing that the filmmaker quotes brings
out a subtle agony from De Niro one
might have seen the actor could no
longer summon what do you wanna know why
not they did that
stephanie's a hair rake at Time magazine
felt similarly writing De Niro gives his
best performance in years with zero
mugging or scowling his Frank is a man
of action who's so busy doing bad stuff
he barely has time to think some may be
wary of the Irishman after hearing that
a clock sinner a staggering two hundred
and nine minutes but most critics have
promised sat the hefty one time as part
of what makes the film so special as the
New Yorkers Richard Brodie Rose it runs
a minute shy of three and a half hours
and I wouldn't wish it any shorter
Brodie certainly wasn't the only one who
felt this way about the Irishman's
runtime at Ivy Club Al said this is a
remarkably brisk three and a half hours
Scorsese at a ripe 76 still directs for
the energy of a hungry young filmmaker
his command of montage yanking the
audience forward from scene to scene
over at Fox Alyssa Wilkinson argued that
quote the near bagginess of the film is
part of its initial charm she continued
the Irishman's longer which involves the
use of largely out of true safety aging
technology means the film follows
Frank's and his associates long past
when the movie usually ends with triumph
or failure the film instead takes a
distinct turn away from Rattata plotting
and revenge toward a frankly stunning
contemplative movement speaking of the
digital de-aging in the Irishman used to
make the Nero
Pesci and Pacino looked decades younger
many critics agree that while it can
briefly take viewers out of the film the
technology only adds to the story
stephanie zakahrik wrote the t aging is
distracting at first the actors eyes
look real but their skin is just a tad
rubbery and flat now and then I have to
stave off a PTSD flashback to Robert
Zemeckis s Polar Express but the special
effects are hardly a deal breaker and in
the end they probably add to the movies
mythological vibe Mike Reider toprock
said that the d aging isn't perfect but
it's worth it writing this is a small
price to pay to get all these actors
together again to tell this story
audiences can decide for themselves how
they feel about the Irishman when the
film opens and a limited capacity on
November 1st then drops on Netflix on
November 27th check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]